مشاهدينا اهلا بكم نبدا بهذه الصور
لانفجار كبير وقع في الضاحيه الجنوبيه في
بيروت قبل قليل وهذه
الصور توضح
بشكل واضح كبر هذا الانفجار وهو انفجار
كما وصف في الانباء انفجار كبير في
الضاحيه الجنوبيه في بيروت في منطقه
المشرفيه في الضاحيه الجنوبيه اذا هذه
الصور تاتينا مباشره من هناك من الضاحيه
الجنوبيه وتحديدا منطقه
المشرفيه في ضاحيه بيروت
الجنوبيه المشرفيه وهي منطقه المشرفيه
الواقعه في ضاحيه بيروت الجنوبيه اذا هذا
انفجار كبير وقع هناك وهذه الصور تاتينا
من منطقه المشرفيه طبعا مازالت الانباء لم
تنقل عدد ان كان هناك اصابات او هناك
ضحايا ولكن ما نشاهده يحي بذلك نرى السنه
او لهيب النيران في هذه المنطقه
والناس في حاله هرع في هذه
المنطقه وحاله
استنفار i